hey guys it is Thursday my name's Jess
this is Dan and we're here to tell you
about the news of it Oh something funny
no no you were supposed to say like have
written something in the script not just
say something funny
that's okay we'll improvise
[Music]
the SUP ei has said that Mass Effect
Andromeda got a little too much
criticism yeah I am also interested to
see what I comment section has to say
about it you guys don't need me to tell
you that Andromeda wasn't exactly
globally well-received but ei boss
Patrick soda Lim thinks the criticism
wasn't all justified
he told game reactor I usually don't do
this but this is one of those places
where I feel like the game got
criticized a little bit more than it
deserved I think the game is actually a
great game yes we have to acknowledge
the fact that there were some things
that maybe we could have done better
absolutely but as a whole if you go in
and buy the game today with everything
that's in it today I believe that's a
game worth flying personally
there you go gang the boss of EA says
the EA game Andromeda is totally worth
buying Jess's excessive salt aside
Andromeda did improve after release with
better less horrifying animations
multiplayer updates and new content that
said Bioware have said that they're
finished with the single-player content
for Andromeda in the series is now on
hiatus so DeLand added that he has hope
for the franchise though saying I see no
reason why we shouldn't come back to
Mass Effect why not it's a spectacular
universe it's a loved series it has a
big fan base and it's a game that has
done a lot for EA and for Bioware he
added that if the series does come back
it will need to be relevant fresh and
exciting you know all the buzzwords from
the 90s do you think mass spec should
come back I think it's fine for you to
bring back anything I mean look at
Assassin's Creed origins this year it
looks like they're making some
significant changes to looks and that's
a win on a sort of hiatus where they
wanted to take it off being an annual
totally so if they want to bring back
Mass Effect with some changes and maybe
have another go at it I'm all for it if
it comes back and it's what we got at
launch for interim it up probably don't
try not to do that again I don't think
it'll happen again I think I will have
learned some really hard lessons just
like
Ubisoft did with Assassin's Creed unity
and I think if they do come back we'll
probably see a better than ever Mass
Effect I think most of the people out
they even wants to really criticize
Andromeda would be happy to see the
franchise return but let me know if I'm
right or not in that comment section
listed have been busy little beavers it
seems they certainly have in the last
week they've announced changes to diva
they brought out a new short about may a
half stone musical number and also a new
map set in Australia for overwatch
called junker town yeah and they're
still not done there's been a massive
overhaul to mercy in the PTR today so
here's the details on that straight out
of the gate Mercy's ultimate is being
replaced entirely currently mercy can
resurrect down team mates with a burst
of invulnerability while casting
resurrect will now be a standard ability
obey it with some changes mercy will be
able to resurrect a single down to
teammate within 5 meters and will no
longer provide invulnerability while
casting I've been gone up against a very
very good mercy the other day who used
invulnerability strategically to escape
my McCree this is welcome news yes her
new ultimate is Valkyrie that quote
unleashes the full power of Mercy's
Valkyrie suit which basically means she
gets a bunch of buffs and the ability to
fly when activated her staff will now
heal or buff all allies near the
targeted teammate and its effective
range has been extended a blaster gets
unlimited mr as well as increased by
right and damage her movement speed is
increased and she gains the ability to
fly freely resurrect is also instantly
reset when her ultimate is activated and
its cooldown is reduced from 30 seconds
to 10 was it have said they made the
changes because quote while resurrecting
downed allies is a core part of Mercy's
gameplay the way her ultimate functioned
was causing a number of problems it was
frustrating to play against and it
incentivized mercy players to hide away
from important battles instead of taking
part in them you can check out the
changes for yourself as they're
currently available along with the
changes to diva in overwatch as public
test realm on PC no word on when these
changes will be rolled out to the full
versions of the game but we'll let you
know as soon as they up finally a
crossover between two of the most
similar titles in the modern gaming
landscape has been announced
Final Fantasy 15 is getting Assassin's
Creed content yes you heard that
correctly starting next week les Talon
will be home to the limited time
Assassin's festival like the Mughal
chocobo Carnival that is currently
running through to the end of September
there will be minigames and exclusive
items as well as gameplay elements from
Assassin's Creed you can get your grubby
mitts on assassins ropes for all four
main characters while noctus can get
master assassins ribs through the dream
egg which you can grab from the moogle
chuck about carnival you'll also be able
to perform a leap of faith so that's
something to look forward to don't worry
if you're busy for the next few weeks
the assassins festival begins on August
31st and will run until January 31st of
next year thank you so much Mary Nick's
for giving me an excuse to roll my
favorite Hideo Kojima video of all time
I'm gonna roll
did you wreck it remember that that was
when there was Assassin's Creed content
in Metal Gear Solid 4 so it's all the
first time something like this has
happened
no and but I have no Final Fantasy and
Assassin's Creed and in the trailer you
see them running around Assassin's Road
well everyone else is in their Final
Fantasy good yeah interesting want me
Final Fantasy you've always liked to
have a little bit of fun see killing 15
I mean they had cup noodle yell say no
sorry I mean whatever man I like the
holiday yeah I can dig it that's
everything we have for you today make
sure you tune in tomorrow for our top 5
news stories of the whole week and make
sure you subscribe to see us every day
of the working week yes thank you so
much for joining us yet again and what
what Dan already says okay let me know
if I'm right or not in that comment
section
[Laughter]